for many kids Christmas morning was the
most exciting day of the year that's
only because most kids don't know the
joy of getting their college midterms
back it also didn't hurt the dr. Sturgis
look like an elf you'll notice that your
grades are lower than expected
that's because Sheldon it's so well he
broke the curve turning your A's and B's
into B's and C's they don't seem happy
about it
maybe you can give them candy hey John
George John Sturges here that's why I
said hey John great I was wondering if
we could go out for a beer and talk what
aren't we talking right now yes but we
had so much fun last time I thought we
could do it again gee John last time you
got drunk and threw up in my glove
compartment I promise to be on my best
behavior and the drinks are on me
that's to our health in Russian
is not placed up Russian
so what's up well Sheldon has been doing
extraordinarily well on his college
physics class no no he made me put his
tests up on the fridge next to miss his
drawing of her hand as a turkey so the
university has taken notice of Sheldon's
talents and they would very much like
him to enroll full-time now we've been
down this road John
Sheldon's only 10 Mary and I both have
jobs we just can't make it work well
that's why they asked me to speak to you
they're looking to sweeten the pot
that's a gambling metaphor a
lesser-known version is sweeten the
kitty I assume the differences regional
but I've no etymologist
this beer is yummy so what are they
offering John they thought it would be
easier on the family if you were
employed at the university really yes
that way you could drive Sheldon and
keep an eye on him while he's there but
I'm football coaches at school even have
teeth oh yes they do they they don't win
much but they lead the league in
injuries well yes that's the thing okay
anyway I believe they're willing to
exceed your current salary by a
substantial amount is there so yes they
thought it would incentivize you John
they're not wrong excellent
yeah what the hell how was dr. Sturgis
he's fine what did you two talk about
science stuff no I bet he talked about
me What did he say about me
Sheldon everything isn't about you hey
go to your room yes sir would you all
talk about Sheldon
the university wants to offer me a
coaching job it'll help to get Sheldon
to go there full-time
oh we talked about this coach might be
too much for him I know that's why I'd
be there you already helped them over
the rough spots I don't know George
can't hurt to see what the offer is
there are more important things than
money that's cute
you should nip that on the pillow
and I'll push that pillow over your face
[Music]